welcome back to the David Pakman show as
you can tell by the sound of my voice or
by the face that you see on the screen
that I am NOT david pakman David is away
on a trip vacation I'm not quite sure he
just asked me to fill in for him while
he was gone and I'm more than happy to
I'm Benjamin Dix and host of the
Benjamin Dixon show you can find all of
my content all of my blogs and articles
all of my videos at the Benjamin Dixon
show calm and you can also register for
my newsletter to the point to the point
is where I use three bullet points to
not only summarize but give you insight
into the most pressing issues of the day
now let's get to the point on this next
story
Steve Benin was invited to an event and
then subsequently disinvited because of
the backlash The New Yorker calm was the
magazine was planning an event coming up
in the next few weeks in which Steve
Bannon was supposed to be the headliner
in the political section in which he was
supposed to have a confrontational
interview with the editor of the
magazine that didn't bode well with
other people who were invited to the
conference this is a quote from the New
York Times this is what they had to say
quote within 30 minutes of one another
John Mulaney Judd Apatow Jack Antonoff
and Jim Carrey said on social media that
they would be pulling out of scheduled
events at the festival right around the
same time when mr. Remnick who's the
editor announced the cancellation of mr.
banners participation Patton Oswalt did
the same thing now for the record I'm
quite sure I muddled their names I some
of them I don't even know who they are
but apparently they're big stars that's
fine but Patton Oswalt had to say this
on Twitter he said I'm out sorry New
Yorker see if my lowly innopolis is free
I think that was a excellent way to put
it because this is the same exact
category that Steve Bennett is in Steve
been and helped launch my no Milo you
Napoles into the national conversation
and so that act that tweet makes
absolute sense Judd Apatow and which
whose
name again I know I'm muddling but it
doesn't matter here's what they had to
say
they said this on Twitter if Steve
Bannon is at The New Yorker festival I
am out I will not take part in the in an
event that normalizes hate I hope the
New Yorker will do the right thing and
cancels the Steve Bennett event maybe
they should read their own reporting
about his ideology and one more Jim
Carrey I'm sure I got that one right
right this is what he had to say he said
quote Bannon and me on the same program
could never happen and so after all of
this all the negative publicity all of
the speakers who are counseling The New
Yorker decided to rescind their
invitation to Steve Bennett Steve Bannon
of course did not take it lightly this
is what he had to say in a statement to
the New York Times he said the following
quote the reason for my acceptance was
simple I would be facing one of the most
fearless journalists of his generation
in what I would call a defining moment
David Remnick showed he was gutless when
confronted by the howling online mob
Steve Bennett you know here's there's a
lot to say about this because this this
treads on the conversation of deep
platforming Nazis deep platforming white
supremacist and other groups and it
intersects in that disagreement that we
have on the Left about free speech
absolutism now and of course this is not
a free speech confrontation or conflict
rather this is an organization saying oh
we made a mistake inviting a jerk to our
platform so we're not going to invite
him anymore
but it will be cast by some as a free
speech problem but here's a question
underneath the you know at what point
have we had enough hearing the same
hateful rhetoric it's not as though
challenging them is sufficient they want
these platforms they have they have
mastered the art of participating in
debates with the most disingenuous
motives possible but they don't operate
in good faith
they will revise history they will just
outright lie and they will do it all for
applause points and no matter how it
plays out no matter how their
confrontation confronted rather with the
truth they will simply deny the truth
and it will get published online as
Steve Benin owns liberal media I mean
this is this is their formula they have
no intention in engaging in good faith
discussions this is a part of their
strategy they deny everything that
they've said even though they've said it
they revise history even though though
most of us understand history pretty
clearly they will look us in the face
and deny it and they will stand on stage
while they're getting booed about lying
and continue to lie because they know
this they don't have to win the debate
with anyone else except their audience
and so long as their audience continues
to support them they will never engage
in a good faith argument it is all
performative so this it makes absolutely
no sense to engage in these debates with
them by giving them a platform that
amplifies them if you want to go to
their turf and you want to tackle them
on their turf on their platforms that
they built fine so be it
but to amplify them and to normalize
them in mainstream media outlets suggest
that there's something of value that can
come from this and there never is
there's never anything of value that can
come from people who will look you in
the eye and say things like Adolf Hitler
was actually a socialist liberal I mean
this is this is the type of revisionist
history that they are engaging in Steve
Benin has demonstrated that he has no
intention of he has no redeeming values
about him that are worthy to be on the
national stage and yet we have media
outlets who are fascinated they just
they're still fascinated with this Trump
phenomenon for one but then for two they
are interested in how many tickets they
can sell by bringing on someone as
controversial as
Steve Bannon this time it backfired on
them and and good on all of the other
people all the stars and people who
rejected this and said I'm not gonna be
a part of this because it is its own
form of exploitation you're putting me
on stage with someone who was a known
bigot for what the chance to show him up
and to show that he's disingenuous or to
show that doesn't matter I mean we're
literally the people whose minds have to
be convinced that Donald Trump is a
maniac who needs to be stopped or the
people whose minds need to be convinced
of the fact that racism is running amok
in this country they're not going to
change their minds their minds have been
made up Donald Trump said this during
the campaign and it's at bones truthful
today that he could stand on Fifth
Avenue and shoot somebody and people
will still support him you know why
because they have reduced this down to
nothing more than how they can own the
lives and they will revise history they
will lie directly to your face they will
be disingenuous in their debates also so
that they can own the lives and so it
makes absolutely no sense to amplify the
message of someone like Steve Bannon on
a mainstream platform like the New
Yorker for the hopes of what because
whatever you're hoping you're going to
accomplish with them you won't
accomplish